a question because like you can't like
from from the first date when you meet
you can't really
this is awesome because you don't know
that you don't know them you
you don't know them at all like you
don't owe them an explanation of what
like it's it's the same as asking like
what are we the first week that you've
been you've seen each other it's like
it's like a better question to ask is
like is there a second day because then
you're not asking okay like what do you
want like you're showing interest like
do you want a second day like what that
my gosh where are you going
yeah i asked you to read that question
again
i was gonna hear it
details of it questions
yeah the question let me scroll up um at
what point after a woman meets a man
does she owe him honesty in her thoughts
and feelings about him
yeah did you okay i think um
because like every like
relationship or situation i guess
kind of rolls at different timings
and i would say like why would you want
to force someone to tell you how they
feel like shouldn't they be the one to
open up to you instead of like you know
tell me how do you feel about me like
wouldn't you rather have them like have
feelings for you and just be like
wanting to tell you you know i feel like
a lot of guys don't like listen to the
signs
where it's like
i don't think
don't actually like to read into things
i think women do
but like men choose not to so or
consciously don't know how to yeah i've
interpreted that question in a very
different way okay i interpret it as in
like if you just met someone in the
first it would come back to the first
date scenario
like should you tell him immediately or
or at some point after the date well i'm
not feeling you let's put up doing this
again rather than deep feelings i think
you guys went for a more emotional deal
oh okay okay swear brood as well
so like during the day like okay let's
say we're on a date like during the day
we're like okay i'm gonna go now because
i'm not feeling the day like i feel like
that would be like really
no no no no you don't see it you don't
see that right there but i think the
question is more like well after you had
a date
like when somebody's like what when
do you keep talking or stringing it long
or she should be honest say actually you
know that we're good meeting you and but
i don't want to see you again i think
it's good courtesy to like um after the
date to write to them and tell them okay
i enjoyed the day or i didn't enjoy the
letter yeah like okay you get your
you're going to get that
stan
get your pigeons
and then
so just like send them a message i'm
like oh i enjoy the day i would like to
have a second day i enjoyed the day but
i don't think we'll have a second date
that's basically the bare minimum but
what house you know again my
interpretation it might be different one
to the reception that's what how soon
after the first day the next day
yeah next day
i don't
no go ahead if i don't like a guy i'd
just text him right out like afterwards
yeah just like get this done
i just let them know the next time they
ask me or if they even do ask me you
know
i just i don't know i'm
i'm very non-confrontational so i know
what you mean i feel like it's quite
difficult as a woman to kind of
i don't know yeah to like break things
off because men will make it they might
make it easier they're like oh like i
don't want to see you again they're like
why i'm like but
isn't this enough
i don't want to get more feedback so you
said something three months ago so you
um dance you said something i'm gonna
challenge it it's not that men don't
want to see signs and read signs we're
not as good at reading inside and seeing
signs as yeah that's right it's not
we're not that we're not we don't we
don't want you so we're not as good as
it as you are so you might be putting
signals out but we just miss them i'm
sure yeah
an example would have liked a guy seen a
guy liked him and you think you did the
most to get his attention he ain't
[ __ ] seeing it he's not he's not yeah
it's like oblivious to it sometimes it's
gonna be we
have to be sometimes to be quite obvious
and quite blatantly with us because
we're not picking we don't get the
subtlety sometimes
yeah but i do feel like
i mean like someone can
i mean i think like just men are they're
just naturally more like logical and
they don't do the
like what does this mean what does this
mean does this mean like we can do a lot
of things but pick up on like little
hints they don't yeah they don't do the
overthinking that we kind of do like we
think like oh everything like kind of
not everything but like you know yeah
you're like you're looking at the
details thing you may really look at the
details and then kind of look at the
general picture what something means so
for example you've got a partner right
maybe anywhere with your partner and
like walked a room with like women and
you like seen them or got a vibe from
them that they're watching your young
man and you're like
she's a [ __ ]
that's the tip no but there's a
territorial coming up what are you
talking about he's not seeing anything
he's not or he's not seen the way you
see she's flirting with him and he's
saying now we're just talking to have a
nice conversation and you see more than
you know is the territorial thing funny
that you say because the other thing
like it was like switched around oh
really yeah and i was like oh like i'm
just like talking to my friends and
they're like and he was like
friends i'm like
yeah like friends like they're not your
friends i'm like okay
if a guy and a girl are in a
relationship right can can the girl have
guy friends and can you can the boy has
yours
do you think like men can really be
friends with women at this point i'm
sorry i
i think okay i think most of the time no
but there are a few exceptions
family friends
i think like if you grew up together you
can have genuine friendships i think
growing up together can lead into that
religion you know into those it can yeah
but but i think like there are genuine
friendships where you grew up together i
think there are genuine friendships
where like sometimes people just live by
each other and like they just become
friends that way yeah like like next one
i become things yeah like or they're in
the same
like friend group i think those are the
three ways where genuine friends happen
like maybe like the sexuality or it's
not
you're not the preference so let's say i
don't want to say like the time like gay
best friend cause that's kind of weird
but like if someone's like not your
preference and your best friends
but you've put them in a friend zone
they usually still might want you so the
question still exists can they still be
friends because you don't want to be a
friend he doesn't want to be a friend i
don't understand but then i think okay
if that was the case though i don't
think that so like we wouldn't know that
would be the case and then so then we
won't pick up on that we will push that
and so like would it be would it really
be our fault if like we're still we
consider like naive to him yeah really
a moment ago we just agreed that women
have better pick up signals and they
both going to tell me that you can have
a guy for not know he's attracted to you
but i would say like
first of all i would say like when you
kind of like categorize that like person
as like a friend then then you say that
you don't see any other signal i
understand that you criticize him as a
friend but you still know that he wants
more than oh if i knew
even even
you know you've never had a god
like attractive friends or like they'll
only be friends with attractive women if
they're going to be friends with them so
that's why i'm really like because they
want you that's why i'm like
yes this is why i'm suspicious of
girlfriends like both ways like i'm
watching out because i i thought it was
innocent but now i i see the last time
i'm sorry it's never innocence
i mentioned this like on one of the
podcasts i've been on before i was like
it sucks sometimes like being a woman
like trying to be friends with guys
because you never know when they
secretly just want to [ __ ] you all the
time
but like in the end when that does
happen it just sucks because then like
you see all these things that you've
done with them and they're like okay
actually didn't mean anything because
all you want to do is [ __ ] yeah and it's
kind of lousy because they went all this
way like they're playing the long game
playing the longest of games just to
[ __ ] you like which is so which is a bad
strategy guys that doesn't work
in mind